it gives me great pleasure to announce
the next speaker for the conference
uh many of you know him by
many names which i probably don't know
uh but one thing i will do want to share
with you is a he's a good friend
um and b you know it's he's been putting
on a great conference over the last
couple years everyone please welcome
jared up on stage
when you're working on a project there
are many moving parts
and each part of this data pipeline has
its own considerations
and those considerations become
more difficult when you're working with
medium data
medium data is harder to handle than
people think it is
it's
big enough that it doesn't fit into
memory
but small enough that you shouldn't be
using google scale tools
so you need to figure out how you're
going to work with it it takes a little
bit of thought so we're going to discuss
some of those tools
and as our motivating example for today
we are going to be talking about taxis
yes that's cash cab and yes i was on it
very very early as one of the first
contestants
the new york city taxi data is publicly
available on aws for anyone to get and
examine in fact it's been used a lot for
medium data case studies
our goal for today
has a few steps in it
first we are going to pull the data from
s3
but we only want to pull the data if it
has changed because we don't want to pay
for that egress fee
then we are going to keep data only from
certain geographic areas of our data
set and then we want to only keep rides
which are which are represented by a row
where all the rides for that given day
were over some threshold say six million
dollars so if all the rides across all
taxis for a given day was over six
million dollars keep the rides for those
days and not other days
then we want to load our cleaned up
ready to go data set into a database
so first up we have to go get the data
and we can do that using the aws.s3
package
using the save object function we're
going to get this object which is in our
case a file from that bucket and save it
to this file locally on disk
and this brings it down
we can
read in the data set just a few columns
using f read take a sample using slice
sample then convert it into an sf object
so that we can plot it with leaflet
and we very quickly see there are a
bunch of taxi pickups in the middle of
the ocean near africa
we probably want to remove those from
our data set
notice for a moment though instead of
using the
add points function from leaflet i'm
using add gl points from leaf gl because
it uses webgl so it can plot much
quicker and it can plot more points than
the standard function can it's a nice
add-on that makes life really really
good
so now we have our data we want to
geo-filter it
and there are a few strategies we can
take
we can
load it up into post-gis right from the
get-go and do a spatial query
but that's our end goal and the data's
not ready for that yet
so we could read all the data into
memory convert it into an sf object and
filter out the rows
but we can't be so certain that the data
will fit into memory
so we can split this one big file into
multiple files then read and filter each
file individually
so that's the strategy i want to go if i
want to split the files
i wrote a function that first deletes
any files in the destination folder
saves the header row to be used later
and then uses process x which we are
going to use a lot to call the bash
command split we call split we give it a
bunch of extra information how we want
the data split up
and then we keep track of all these
files we generated
when we run this command and we take a
look at the output directory we have 319
files plus a header file
so our data is all split up and we can
operate over that
in order to do the geofiltering we first
need a map of our desired area
luckily that is freely available online
and we can read it straight from the url
which is hosted by arcgis into read sf
and we are going to use this map to keep
just some records
we check out the map to see we have each
borough of new york city and we are just
going to focus on manhattan just make
the problem a little bit quicker for
today
also please note that this map used
exactly four colors and according to the
four color theorem you can plot any map
with just four colors and i think we
just proved it with this one simple
example
so now it's time to do our spatial
filter and we're going to do this for
each of our hundreds of files so i wrote
a function to do that
first it reads in the header because not
all of our split files have headers
then we use f read for its speed to read
in this one file
convert it to a table because it's
easier for me to work with
convert that into an sf object and set
the lat long
then we'd use st filter
st filter is like a spatial join but
it's only going to keep the
columns from the first table and it's
going to reduce the rows based on which
points in the first table fall into the
polygons of the second table
after we have filtered down our data
notice this is all just one long
pipeline
we then convert our geometry object away
from well-known text where it's stored
into an ewkb that is a special type of
well-known binary because we could save
that in the csv and load that into post
gis very nicely
and we said hex equals true so it comes
across as text instead of raw
and then we use f right to write this
out to a file
and we do that for each file
individually and we mix very nicely data
table d plier and sf
we check before we can apply the
function actually
we have to create a mapping of all of
our input files this raw files and the
corresponding output file that way we
can iterate over this data frame and do
is do this one file at a time
we then delete any files that already
exist in our output directory
and use walk to iterate over
this data frame of file names calling
remove points on each file individually
once we accomplish this we read in one
data set to see what it looks like we
have all the columns we expect and our
geometry column the last one is stored
as a character because it is a
well-known binary not a raw
standard geometry column
with our
data filter geographically we can now
filter based on an aggregation
we want to only keep the rides from days
where the daily total was above a
threshold
so you can no longer do this one file at
a time because you don't know which rows
are split into which file
i need to be able to look at the entire
data set and a great tool for that is
arrow
this will allow me to operate on the
entire data set
without pulling it all into memory while
still using a d plier syntax this is
going to be very very helpful for us
now installing aero even though it's on
cran
can be a little difficult especially on
linux especially in an air-gapped
environment
so luckily there is this github content
which has a function called install
arrow which will install the arrow
system libraries for you to make it a
little bit easier to have the package
going in r
to do this step i wrote another function
so it's easy to apply because there are
multiple steps in this process
first we use open dataset to open the
entire data
we are not reading it all into memory
but we are making it available to us and
that's the nice thing it is not all in
memory it is just being a made available
to us and that's very important
we then compute a group by summarization
we group by date we summarize by summing
up the
total fare and then we filter out to
make sure that fares were over a certain
threshold now this has not been computed
we've just constructed the query
we will then use this query in a semi
join which is a filtering join that will
only keep records of our main data set
which have a date corresponding to this
filtered outdates
and then we write this result out to a
file
only parts of the data ever make it into
memory which is really really awesome
so then we call this function and we
check it out and it produced one file we
could have written multiple files but i
want just one for our next step which is
loading to the database this is our
ultimate goal of getting it in here and
for my purposes one file will be easier
dealing with databases can be a bit
tricky sometimes
so
instead of installing the database
directly i am going to use docker i'm
going to use to hold the database this
way i can't screw up other databases
rather than build my own docker
container i'm going to use an existing
one cartoza post gis and i will use
docker compose for spinning it up
i'm using a volume to store the database
data that way survives reboots
there's also a nice feature that any sql
files i put into a certain volume
will be ran the first time the container
is spun up
i also set certain environment variables
like setting a really secure password
such as docker
and i make sure there are extensions
such as post gis and h-store and some
other ones
and i declare the port to be 5436
because i have multiple of these
containers going on for all my projects
and they can all use the same port
that sql file that creates a table
has a regular crate statement with a
bunch of columns each of different types
including our geometry column with
constraints to make sure it is a point
not a polygon not a line string but a
point
i don't set any indexes because i'll do
that later after i load the data
to spin up the container
i use process x from inside of r and i
call the bash command docker compose i
tell it
which docker compose file to use because
i have multiples i tell it up and dash d
means detach it this way it doesn't clog
up my terminal
with our database running we can finally
copy from the csv into that table
but we are not going to use r to do this
because that whole csv might not fit
into memory instead we will use psql a
command line tool which reads straight
from a csv into
the database
and i need to provide a set of sql
instructions
this file starts with begin and ends
with commit
and that means that all these steps are
part of a transaction
if any one step fails it will undo all
the steps and that's really important
it's a really great way of making sure
you don't screw up massively always use
a transaction
first we drop the indexes because it'll
be quicker to delete and bulk load into
the database without indexes
we delete all the rows in the current
table that we care about
because we're just doing a delete and
replace and then we slash copy
into that table from our csv
and we tell the
program that it is a csv with a header
row and blanks to be treated as nulls
now this line of code should all be on a
single line
i have broken it up onto multiple lines
so you can read it but it has to be on a
single line
after slash copy we create the indexes
and then we commit so it's a really
great way of writing to the database
slash copy is really incredibly fast
when i call psql i will not be able to
pass in a password so i need to provide
that some other way
and i do that by storing all the
database information including our super
secure password in a config file
called.pg underscoreservice.conf
we put all of our connection information
inside of this file and then when we
call psql it gets the password
automatically
super easy really works really well we
then use process x to call p sql
and when we do that we say service
equals medium data so it knows to use
this database information that we got
from
our service file
and we provide the file of instructions
using dash f
so all those steps were really great
they
a lot of them
depend on each other it could be a lot
of complication you don't want to make
sure you want to make sure you don't
duplicate
so it's important to use some sort of
orchestration tool you want to run those
pieces smartly you want to run them in
the right order you don't want to repeat
steps you don't want to have to worry
about memory usage
thankfully we have targets this puts
everything together it only runs steps
that need to be re-ran it doesn't waste
any computation
it builds the dag for us the directed
acyclic graph it moves objects in and
out of memory it's very reproducible and
it's really changed my entire workflow
when you're using targets your directory
structure typically looks like this
you keep all your custom code
particularly your functions inside the r
folder inside a file called functions.r
the naming is optional
then you put
all of your instructions inside of
underscoretargets.r
everything goes inside of there
we'll look at that extensively you set
config and underscore targets.yaml
i put my database instructions inside
copy2db.txt you may or may not have that
i put my database files inside the
database folder and i have a docker
compose file for spinning up my
container
today we are going to focus on targets.r
inside there you call library targets
and optionally target types which gives
you more advanced versions of targets
you source any code you need by sourcing
in this case our functions then all of
your commands all of your steps go
inside of a list a plain old regular r
list nice super simple
so let's go back to the beginning where
we started and let's get the data
we use tarforce to first check has the
file changed because we don't want to do
this if the file hasn't changed
tarforce calls getbucketdf which tells
us if the file has changed and if it has
changed our next step calls save object
to download it
this target is a tar file because the
outcome of this function is the name of
a file on disk and later steps we'll
check if that file has changed and tar
file keeps track of that for us
we can visualize our dac by calling
tarviz network
even though we only had two steps it
shows us three because tar force is
actually two and one
typically this visualization
only will show the difference between
outdated targets and up-to-date targets
but since i use tarforce that runs every
time so even though subsequent targets
will be up to date they will still be
shown as outdated and there's nothing we
can do about that right now
next we need to split the data
luckily we wrote a function for that and
we can call that function
first we split the data and this times
the tar target it's a regular target
because an r object is returned a data
frame of file names
and that feeds into our next target
which creates a mapping of input files
and output files
when we visualize our dag now we see we
have these extra steps and the raw file
step will only be called if the raw data
step is changed and that is only changed
if we downloaded the data which only
happens if the file on s3 changes
to our geofiltering we need our map of
our desired area so we need to go
download it again we only want to
download it if it has changed so tar url
given a url on the internet will keep
track of that file on the internet and
we'll
let you know if that file has changed
remotely if it hasn't changed you're
good if it has changed the next step tar
target which reads in this url into sf
will be fired so it's a great way of
keeping track of files that are remote
to you so you don't have to worry about
if they have changed
this part of the dag has just two steps
checking if the file is changed on the
internet and reading it into an sf
object
you can see that these two steps are
completely disconnected from the rest of
the dag they're independent of each
other because they don't have anything
to do with each other
for now
because next we're going to do our
spatial filtering and that's going to
combine our data and that map file
to do this first we make a list of any
existing filtered files in our output
directory and we delete them all we
don't want them around because we don't
we don't want overlap
we then
take our data frame of input and output
files and we map over that see the
pattern equals map that allows us to
iterate over one row at a time of this
data frame
to call our function remove points on
each one individually
you can see here that this function
depends upon
our nyc map our file name mapping and
in curly braces we included remove
filtered files because even though our
function doesn't make use of it i want
this step to only occur after that
removing data step has been successful
looking at the dag now we see that
removing the old files making the input
output list and the nyc map all feed
into filter files
now filtered files is a square not a
circle
because rather than one step it is a
pattern of steps because it's going to
be called for each of those rows in the
data frame so it's iterating over that
pattern
with our data all processed we can now
do our aggregation based filtering
this step uses tar change because our
function which calls arrow doesn't
actually refer to any of the previous
steps so i'm saying change equals the
filter file step so if those files
change
go ahead and run the step
the outcome this of this step will be a
file so i say format equals file
and i tell it to load up the package
arrow because this way i don't need to
specify the arrow namespace in that
function
targets and arrow don't really play
nicely together so you need to create
and destroy the arrow object within a
single target
and this gets even harder if you want to
share schemas
our dag now shows the process files
which will only run if the filter files
have changed
next up we need to get the docker
container running
so i create a step called docker up and
i actually have a list our step is a
list it has two parts to it
because your steps can be
any valid r object
the first step calls docker compose like
we saw earlier this spins up the docker
container
but since column docker composed on
container that's already running gives a
different message than on a new
container i also check when was this
container created and i will use that
later to let us know if we should run
other steps
this docker up step is this one step by
itself disconnected from the rest of the
dag
with our database running we can copy
from the csv to the table
so we want to call our process x to call
p sql we need to remember to feed it our
database information
which is medium data this way it gets
the password
and this step runs
if either the docker uptime changed or
the process file itself changes that's
why we use tar change and specify the
change
our dag is now complete we have all of
our steps we need to take all laid out
for us right here and everything will
happen nicely and automatically
and if we say targets only equals false
it also shows us our custom functions to
make sure that we know if our function
has changed it changes the graph
so now we can run the whole pipeline or
at least whatever needs to be updated by
running one line of code we run tar make
and everything just runs all nicely
taken care of for us if things don't
need to be run they don't need to be run
if they do they do
but better yet
we can do this in parallel
that's really great
let's take advantage of our split files
remember we had hundreds of them
and let's do each one individually in
parallel
the first step to this is setting
pattern equals map equals
file name of mapping this iterates over
all those files and since they are done
independently they can be done in
parallel
next up in our arrow step we need to be
careful here
arrow runs implicitly in parallel
already and we want to keep it in
parallel
but we don't want a race condition with
our other parallel steps we want both so
we set deployment equals main for the
arrow step and that will run by itself
in parallel and then all everything else
will run in parallel also
we then make one change to
our targets file we say
future plan
of future multi-session and i set four
workers i could have done more workers
but i said four workers and now anything
that can be done in parallel will that
means if you have two steps that have
nothing to do with each other they can
run in parallel
if you have a step like our
geoprocessing which maps over a bunch of
files that will be done in parallel
if you have a step which uses a function
like future map that will be done in
parallel it's all nicely done for you
and the one more change we need to make
is instead of calling tar make
we call tar make future
that's it that runs everything in
parallel even across multiple machines
if you wanted to you'd actually run
tarmac cluster mq but same idea and this
runs everything in parallel for you you
don't need to worry about it you just go
along from there and go on your smooth
road
so we put together a lot of different
tools let's see what we did
we used aws for cloud storage
we use the command line for splitting
and pre-processing files
we use data table for reading and
writing data
and then d plier and per for data
manipulation
we use sf for geospatial filtering
we use arrow for operating on out of
memory data
postgres and postgis for holding the
finished data
docker isolating the database
and targets for orchestrating everything
and this is great this package put
everything together built the dag it
keeps track of what needs to be computed
it's easier than other orchestration
tools and it is all r
based and that one package pretty much
sums up the whole project literally it
gives us the whole project right here in
this one visualization tells us
everything that's happening and does it
all for you allowing you to combine all
these tools to help you work on data
that would otherwise give you a bit of
trouble
thank you very much